-Brexit has been in the news
a lot lately,
and there's still quite a few
people, specifically Americans,
who don't fully understand it.
Luckily, I saw this commercial
last night that I think
explains everything you need
to know about the topic.
Let's take a look.
♪♪ -Happy birthday to you ♪♪
-Oh!
-Thanks, you guys!
-Oh, I love
our little get-togethers.
-Well, you know what
I don't love?
-What?
-Not understanding everything
that's going on
with the world today.
-It's so confusing.
-Like, for example,
what is Brexit?
-I'm pretty sure Brexit's the
most important meal of the day.
[ Laughter ]
-Not quite.
Brexit is just a term for
Britain's recent decision
to leave the European Union.
-Tell me more.
-Well, some British people
want to control
their own trade agreements
instead of having them
controlled
by a larger, unorganized body,
while other British people think
it's better to be part of
a group of bodies
that all work together.
-Like an orgy.
-I still don't understand
what Brexit is.
-It's simple.
The vote for Brexit
was called by David Cameron,
the former Prime Minister
of the United Kingdom
who never thought it would pass.
But then it did,
so he stepped down.
Then he was replaced by
Theresa May,
who was initially against Brexit
but now is in charge of
carrying it out.
-The way I'm in charge of
carrying my dog out
when he needs to go
to the bathroom.
He has dementia.
-Then in November, negotiators
agreed on the framework
for the future relationship
between the E.U. and the U.K.,
which is not
a binding legal document
but more of a commitment
to negotiate in good faith,
which is set out in Article 184
of the withdrawal agreement.
-Well, that clears
everything up.
-Oh, no, it doesn't.
-So did the U.K.
leave the E.U. or not?
-Well, the majority of citizens
voted to leave. So, yes.
But then they spent two years
debating how to leave. So, no.
But then Theresa May made a new
law saying they have to leave.
So, yes!
But then Parliament
rejected her deal.
So who knows?
-I do now.
-No, you don't.
-Sure, I do.
-So are they leaving?
-They're trying.
Imagine a divorce.
-A girl can dream.
-While Britain is definitely
leaving the E.U....
-E-u!
Sorry, I just farted.
-They just haven't worked out
the terms.
But either way,
they'll exit on March 29th.
-March 29th, that's my birthday.
-Wait, if March 29th
is your birthday,
then why are we eating
this cake?
-I guess I had a brain Brexit.
[ Laughter ]
-America. Be glad we got out of
Britain when we did.